let's go next to wasif from dhaka
welcome
hello it's been a while thank you for
you know
picking me protocol i guess pleasure
hear me yes from bangladesh
yes yes okay so my question is you know
more or less related to you know
the
gun topic i guess you could say the gun
control issue or you know whatever you
may call it sure uh this is what i think
you know like i have heard this phrase
you know
mainly among you know these zionist
americans i mean even you know ben
shapiro went to you know let's say
what's his name or pierce morgan pierce
morgan's tv show right and he basically
you know stated at this point so
therefore his point was basically like
this that you know our ancestors in you
know eastern europe are in ashes because
they didn't have guns to protect that's
why we need you know less gun
restrictions basically
yeah i've addressed that before it's
crazy i have addressed it yeah um
so uh yeah i mean listen ben shapiro's
jewish i'm jewish he has fallen for this
talking point that if the jews had had
guns the holocaust wouldn't have
happened historians have looked at the
claim
um it's just the the facts aren't true
and the conclusion isn't true
guns were not initially even banned uh i
mean there's so many reasons why it's
historically inaccurate but i can assure
you that handguns and rifles would not
have prevented the holocaust
obviously i'm just i'm asking you
because you know i know you're jewish
right this is what that's why you know i
could have asked this question to you
know let's say anyone else
uh
doing you know similar work as you like
you know leftist podcasts right
but i chose you specifically to ask this
question because i knew you know your
background was jewish okay thank you for
taking my call well my answer has
nothing to do the whole i think the
important thing is my answer is just
based on what historians have written
about it um and me being jewish doesn't
doesn't change that uh okay well thank
you for the call i uh i really
appreciate it
all right there goes wasif great to hear
from him